the wife of the man who was killed
during tuesday night's hit and run
speaking out and outrage pedro martinez
acampo was arrested in connection to the
crash but expected to be released very
soon christian casares now with the
details
joanne irishman is devastated about the
loss of her husband but furious over the
fact that the person who allegedly
caused the crash is not staying behind
bars
i'm not used to not having him around
we've been together so long i'm not used
to not happening real
and the dog she constantly looks for him
it's been a heartbreaking and emotional
couple of days for joanna irishman since
she was notified that her husband
stephen was killed less than a block
away from her north las vegas home he
was on his way out
to the dollar store he says i'm going to
go by the dollar store you want to come
i said no i don't feel like coming
i said i'm going to stay home he said
okay
and he left according to north las vegas
police 36-year-old pedro martinez ocampo
was speeding on decatur in a pickup
truck when he hit a car south of gowan
and killing the driver ocampo fled the
scene but was shortly located and
arrested that victim was joanne's
husband of 27 years ocampo faces several
charges including dui leaving the scene
and possession of a firearm while under
the influence
thursday morning results from ocampo's
blood draw were still pending at the
time of his first court date and he is
expected to be released from custody
he's due back in court june 16th they've
seen everything they knew what happened
i hope he doesn't kill more people i
hope not i hope that he doesn't ruin
other people's lives the way he's ruined
mine
irishman tells me she plans on attending
ocampo's court date on june 16th in
place of celebrating her wedding
anniversary christian casa is live local
now